it's windy and cold back to you
now get your jackets out everybody it is
a cool morning for sure a beautiful shot
as we've got that leftover full moon
this week hanging over the western
mountains this morning the spring
mountains it is nice and clear top wind
speeds have been over 30 miles an hour
out at red rock down in boulder city
over the hump in brump at 32 mile an
hour winds and harry reid international
near 30 mile per hour winds we've got a
lot of areas that have been getting some
gusts to about 25 miles an hour so all
these 40s that we've got temperatures
are chillier than yesterday plus factor
in those wind chills and sometimes it's
feeling like the 30s this morning so
warm jackets get those kids ready for
school with some warm jackets please 41
up in mesquite not much wind up there in
the moapa valley 33 in indian springs 42
in perum and 54 in loughlin where yes we
have had some definitely some pretty
good wins down there this is the big
story of the day though it's that huge
cold front with strong jet stream winds
out ahead of the front is rain but on
the back side of it is snow and it has
been very slippery cold cold air you can
see look at the temperatures below
freezing up in the north and through the
mid-south and the plains but boy out
ahead of it 60s anywhere from little
rock to nashville even 70s down in
jacksonville and new orleans this
morning it's the clash of the air masses
live picks coming in from driving in the
snow to the
to the freezing rain and sleet this in
kansas city boy this is a much different
commute than what we've got to deal with
this morning snowy roads galore thank
goodness we're not dealing with this but
unfortunately this area of the country
which is huge millions of people dealing
with this weather today
might have to be dealing with severe
weather maybe even some tornadoes later
all right let's get back to our forecast
we're looking at 63 today with these
northerly winds
up to 25 miles an hour generally through
the day calmer tonight and chilly 40 for
the morning low there will be a lot of
neighborhoods in the 30s for friday
morning nice sunshine to finish the week
and get into the beginning of the
holiday weekend even some 70s saturday
sunday but boy here comes the next
system wow another cold one out of the
gulf of alaska this one's going to drop
into the west southwest we're looking at
wind a chance of rain mountain snow on
presidents day monday followed by some
cool 50s for highs and mornings back in
the 30s next week